all right just a quick fyi guys uh
tomorrow on sunday i know we normally do
invincible and then we do uh green
lanterns i want to take tomorrow off
like i just need a day to just
relax and just kind of reorganize myself
and get structured i've been running
myself ragged recently so i'm kind of
going nuts but at the event uh so we're
covering power rangers here right we're
recovering this whole thing thank you to
you guys for not dumping spoilers right
i really appreciate that because i'm
going to tell you right now
what's coming dude this this dude the
new ranger who shows up man this guy
is op in the worst way so so here's a
crazy thing
there is a little bit of a prelude to
this it's not overly important so we're
not we're going to kind of like skim
over that right but there is something
that happens at the end of the prelude
before we kind of get to everything else
that is really important here
the whole idea is you have like the
president of italy who kind of talks
about like reader repulsa and we're not
really worried about her yada yada you
know she can't scare us so on and so
forth and then she ends up unleashing
like this giant monster on italy
the power rangers respond jason kind of
jumps in and does this thing
zach ends up powering the megazord in
order to kind of save the day there's a
little bit of a frustration there in the
sense that jason got a little carried
away with himself and almost got himself
when the prime minister killed how the
zord not stepped in
the whole reason why that matters is
because rita actually ends up snatching
up zack and then bringing him directly
to her headquarters and it's kind of
like hey look had jason not done what he
done
then like you know everything would have
been cool but obviously he was trying to
be a glory hound and all that kind of
stuff basically trying to turn
zach against jason the whole thing about
this and the reason why she's doing this
is because she's trying to get zach
to basically defect from the rangers and
join her
group right just kind of become an evil
power ranger more or less zach isn't
really having it and she's kind of
teasing him with like the dragon zord
ring right that he has to cast aside his
own powers that he has to accept the
dragon zord ring a lot of you guys are
already familiar with this kind of stuff
from you know years past with the power
rangers the important thing about all
this is two things happen
one zach of course turns her down which
we would expect right and then zack
ultimately goes to zordon kind of
explains everything that's going on and
he's like you know i was almost tempted
the last thing that happens and the most
important thing that happens is that
rita talks about the idea of they're
gonna need a blank slate they're gonna
need somebody who's a loner obviously
she's referring to
tommy oliver but in this moment when
she's talking to goldar about all this
stuff
a disembodied voice seemingly comes out
of nowhere and he basically says like
this guy tommy's gonna leave you right
he's going to turn on you and he's going
to join the power rangers and when rita
not knowing who this guy is it's like
who in the world saying this like who's
talking then he kind of responds when
you're truly ready to rule the earth
when you realize that i'm right then you
will see me
so that's an incredibly important thing
because that basically sets the stage
for the first real encounter between
this guy who owns the black dragon
and then in turn the conflict between
all the other power rangers and this guy
showing up on behalf of rita repulsa and
so picking up with the last video that
we had
you basically end up having this guy
kind of manifesting himself right
appearing against all the rangers
and the funny thing about this is that
what ends up happening here the rangers
are kind of like all right guys this
guy's an enemy just like anybody else
let's take care of him he immediately
blasts them right just immediately blast
them and it's almost like their skins
being torn off
and of course they managed to recoup a
little bit but at the end of the day
they are
crushed in no uncertain terms right
there's there's
nothing about this fight that indicates
that the power rangers will come out on
top right let me make that clear
there's nothing here in this conflict
that indicates that they even had a
chance for success
these guys are readily destroyed not
even in hell would you see a massacre
like this
it's absolutely crushing and so a couple
things happen one of the things that
takes place here is this guy
has a special interest in tommy which is
really interesting like he's kind of
like you know like you and i
are going to go toe-to-toe at some point
along the line the other thing he does
he knocks out billy the blue ranger and
then tells rita wherever
we're ready whenever you are and of
course all the other power rangers are
basically teleported to a kind of pocket
dimension and then in turn
billy's taken away and so the result of
this is the big question they have here
is
who is this guy man like this guy just
dismantled us like
worse than the green ranger did when he
first showed up because the green ranger
is better than all of us
because everybody knows that because the
green with evil series i always i kept
saying envy in the last video i know
it's green with evil my people were like
actually rob it's green with uh green
with evil there's the name of the
episode i already know what it was
right i just kept calling it envy
because i'm just used to saying envy but
nonetheless this is one of those things
where they're like yeah you know the
green ranger is infinitely better than
all of us because we suck compared to
him and he crushed us all
right like it's just it's absolute
craziness and so that's kind of the big
issue is
one as they're watching on a kind of
view screen to sort of see what's
happening because obviously going back
there would more or less be a death
sentence
a few things are going on one rita is
actually kind of surprised by this guy
and it's like i mean i didn't really
expect you to show up and like destroy
the whole command center but i mean hey
you did your job
you did exactly what you were supposed
to do but then the other thing that rita
has is if they escape to a pocket
dimension
we can't follow them and we can't
destroy them and the response to this
guy in the black dragon is it doesn't
matter and so what he ends up doing is
taking the ranger coin
the power coin of the blue ranger and
then using it to basically tap
into the morphing grid using the green
chaos crystal
and then literally cuts all the power
rangers off to their power right they
they can't be power rangers anymore the
only exception is the green ranger but
like they all lost access to their
abilities man
this guy is crushing them all like it's
just it's
man it's it's amazing it's it's see
here's here's here's the thing
i'm gonna i'm gonna you know what i can
admit things i never took the power
rangers comics
seriously i never cared about them i was
like buying more from power rangers i
mean look this show was amazing it's one
of the best shows in the history of the
world i don't care what anybody says but
how good could the comic
possibly be man let me tell you
something it's on a whole different
level son
i was not ready right so so what you end
up doing here is switching over to
billing this this is probably one of the
coolest moments
in this whole little story here and the
reason why is because what the comics do
that the tv show just didn't do more or
less because of the nature of the show
right it was designed to be like a
an entertaining kids show more or less
so you can only get into deep
philosophical ideas
so long before like you lose the
interest of kids and at the end of the
day all we wanted to do was see him
fight right karate like we thought it
was the coolest thing ever and so what
you get is like some amazing development
here
with goldar and it's a cool thing
because when billy's basically taken to
the dark dimension where goldar is also
being held captive remember goldar
failed to catch tommy and the punishment
that he's enduring as a result of his
failure
is he's in the dark dimension by all
standards of measurement he's been cast
out of rita's inner circle she doesn't
have any interest in him anymore
and that's one of the things that billy
kind of hits on he's like why are you
here and she basically says because i
failed to catch the the green ranger and
now i'm i'm in my shackles as punishment
the you know like the emperor's
punishment is just
billy's like but you failed a lot man
like you've you failed
a lot like every time that you've faced
against us so
why is this any different and that's why
you kind of get this thing where even
goldar never really seemed to consider
that like why is this
any different but one of the things that
that billy kind of says like after some
times passes like are we not even really
going to talk to each other at all and
goldar's like there's nothing to discuss
and that's when billy kind of hits on
this like i mean we're both prisoners
like at the very least we have that in
common and that's one of the funny
things that he kind of notices he's like
but here's the thing man
like where i come from the response is
the enemy of my enemy is my friend
and can you really call yourself an ally
of rita repulsa
right i mean she's locked you away in
here for failure
which seems to be worse given what
you've done you're not part of her inner
circle anymore
she doesn't really care about you or
have any interest in you anymore like
do you really believe she sees you in
the same capacity that you see her like
you have this sworn loyalty to rita
repulsa and look where it landed you
can you really say she's somebody worth
following this is a great conversation
between these guys because more often
than not
you know goldar in the old power rangers
tv show was like goldar you know i've
got the mouth that doesn't really move
it just goes up and down and like yeah
rita we're gonna get the power rangers
and you know nonsensical statements and
things like that and it was it was
interesting
you know for what it was but seeing this
conversation between these two
characters
is awesome because it basically reveals
the side of goldar that like we haven't
really seen before and so i love that
whole conversation between the two but
nonetheless kind of jumping back
to everything that's going on one of the
big things that's taking place here is
in a lot of ways
tommy coming to grips with what's going
on here the power rangers again kind of
losing their power
is no small thing or at least losing
access to their power is no small thing
zordon is nowhere to be found alpha
alpha 5
is gone right i mean we end up knowing
that he's more or less just kind of been
torn to pieces like
literally rita repulses holding his head
in her hands and talking to him you know
and so it's it's kind of nuts but
nonetheless all this
is really tommy kind of taking it on the
shoulders and sort of almost coming to
this belief that it all seems to
you know rest on his shoulders that this
all really seemed to kind of start with
him
right that he was the power ranger that
rita created he defected
and since then there's almost been this
just kind of you know unrelenting desire
of rita repulsa to take out the power
rangers
more so than ever before the other thing
that goes on here and this is a really
cool moment rita repulsa basically
contacts the world and she's like okay
so here's the thing right like i'm
speaking in a language that regardless
of where you are in the world you will
understand in your native language i
have
basically taken out all the power
rangers right like they're gone they're
destroyed and in their place
uh i have taken over their home so like
there's no rangers to protect you not
only that she's also got control of
all of their zords so she basically says
like here's what's gonna happen right to
the presidents the the kings the
dictators
you have 24 hours to come to your senses
any nation that does not pledge loyalty
will become my enemy and i will conquer
you by force
one way or another right like i will
take you out and i will rule this world
and there's literally almost nothing
they can do to stop her
now the other big thing about this is
because of the fact that tommy is not
cut off from the morphin grid and
because of the fact that the power of
the green ranger
taps into the morphin grid in a
different capacity this still allows him
access
to the dragonzord so you end up getting
tommy and you get jason who basically
bore the dragonzord with a with this
idea of traveling directly to the moon
to grab billy because billy is seemingly
the only one because of his intelligence
the only one that can kind of get them
back on track i mean when it comes to
like in comparison to billy
let's be honest with ourselves the other
power rangers are kind of idiots right
but like everybody sort of has something
to offer
right like zack's kind of the cool guy
sometimes depending on the circumstances
he didn't have that cool little dance
maneuver and like the intro in the show
which was kind of weird
jason's of course the leader and then
trini is you know the one who's kind of
working with billy to become
you know more scientific or whatever it
is and then kimberly's just like the one
everybody wants to bang right so it's
like you know it's one of these things
where it's like everybody kind of has
their role to play
when it comes to like all the different
power rangers but the cool thing about
this
is that you end up having jason and
tommy who show up on the moon
and then in the middle of all that you
have zach and trini who are back in
their little pocket dimension and
they're contacted by alpha five right
now alpha five is able to do this
using like a backup system so he's not
completely out but it's like having a
power generator
eventually the batter the battery will
run out and when it does then alpha
flies out of commission and so the big
question they have is like what's going
on out there right like what's the whole
motivation behind all this stuff now
at that point you jump back to tommy and
jason and the whole thing behind this is
like
you know tommy's basically gonna run in
right as the only guy that really has
any powers it makes the most sense
jason's powering the dragon's ward which
is pretty awesome to see
jason controlling the dragon zord it's
cool like
if you never if you are never a huge fan
of power rangers the the significance of
that's probably lost on you but like for
me as a power rangers fan like
it's amazing man but in the middle of
all that you have like the black dragon
who appears and of course
one of the things that's kind of given
to us here is this guy can alter his
size right he can take he can kind of
shrink down
to the size of what is essentially a
regular ranger like a regular size human
being or grow to the size of a zord and
that's nuts man because this guy goes to
like literally take on jason with the
the dragon sword and jason's like
okay let's do this and then wham he just
gets knocked into space
he just gets sent flying into space and
that's it right and then at that point
the you know the
black dragon comes flying right down
onto tommy and he's like okay
let's take care of this man like let's
get down to business and that's one of
the funny things is because
jason's able to recover but the biggest
problem is the dragon zord's just kind
of flying out of control right so one is
stabilizing it and then two trying to
bring it back
the other thing that tommy does here and
it's kind of a genius thing jason kind
of hits a tommy and saying look this guy
is huge like he's enormous compared to
you which means he can't maneuver in the
same capacity you can
so use that to your advantage and so
what tommy ends up doing is literally
grabbing like this
massive energy cannon which is one of
the coolest things
ever and then fires it off at the black
dragon the problem here is it doesn't
work
the black dragon just like catches the
energy in his hands and it's just like
was that it like was that your big plan
like literally just like claps
right it just shuts down the energy and
it's like okay so like that that what
what was the point of all this like i
mean is that was that was that your idea
you're gonna be able to pick up a giant
gun
like your rocket raccoon and shoot me
with it no man
that's not gonna happen and so what you
end up having is tommy
who actually kind of starts playing a
few games with this guy and says you
know like it says
this is an awful lot that like you have
to be 30 stories tall
in order to defeat me and so ultimately
like black dragon ends up shrinking down
and from tommy's perspective that's what
he needs right he's like i need this guy
to be my height so i can take this guy
on face to face and we can call it a day
and so now like he jumps and he's like
you just made a big mistake and before
he can even finish
finish the the word bam like he's
immediately taken out by this guy right
and this guy
actually goes in for the kill and then
hesitates for a second now this
momentary hesitation is what gives jason
the ability to jump in and take this guy
out right to basically
i mean not really destroy him but at the
very least to like tear off a piece of
his arm and then grab that and just
teleport away at this point it's just
they're just fleeing for their lives man
like i mean obviously the mission is
a is a total failure right like it's a
complete failure aside from the arm they
get back
that's basically it there's not really a
whole lot they can do here and so
there's this really cool conversation
that sort of takes place between
rita and the black dragons and one of
the things that rita noticed is that
with the with this black dragon guy he
hesitated against tommy and that's one
of the things she's kind of curious
about right he kind of says like i
underestimated the green ranger it won't
happen again
and she's like i don't understand why
you can't like warp his powers away the
way you do with the other rangers that's
when we kind of learned that like he
accesses the morphin grid in a different
way so it's not easily done
or really doesn't seem to be able to be
done at all but one of the things that
happens when it comes to this
conversation about tommy he doesn't
really answer the question of why it is
that he didn't
kill him when he had the chance but then
he kind of offers a bit of a reprieve
and saying like
i want him to be a hundred percent when
i kill him honestly that's
no real measure of an answer at all
because it doesn't really give us any
actual insight into why he's so
interested in tommy all it really shows
us
is that he wants tommy to be in at 100
indicating that he wants tommy to
understand the full depths of his
failure and how incredibly outclassed he
really was but outside of that we don't
really have an answer here and so that's
one of the things where you switch back
over to all the other rangers and tommy
actually comes in with this great idea
right
and one of the things that he says is
okay look so when this guy took away all
your powers
it's because he used a combination of
his energy blast basically right as
plasma blast
along with the chaos crystal and then in
turn
channeling it directly into billy's
power coin which basically allowed him
to access the morphin grid which shut
down all your powers
and so when with alpha 5 kind of kind of
operating and listening in behind the
scenes
the question he that tommy poses here is
i wonder if we can do that with my power
ring if we use my power ring as this
kind of conduit because it doesn't tap
into the morphin grid and by
by traditional means it's kind of a
separate path then does that mean i can
give you guys
my powers and alpha five is you know
kind of replies and says yeah
hypothetically that should work the
problem is it'll leave you powerless and
so at the end of the day tommy's like
small price to pay this is huge because
in the last video that we talked about
one of the things that we discussed
is that tommy always saw himself as an
outlier right even when he was there
among the power rangers they didn't
really see himself as one of the power
rangers he just
happened to be with the power rangers
and by all standards of measurement
right like he was one of them like we
look at him
his powers don't come from the morphin
grid in the exact same way but at the
end of the day
he's a power ranger he's got a colored
theme he's basically he has a dragon man
like i mean this guy was essentially a
mighty morphin power ranger but because
of his backstory because of his history
his involvement with 3d repulsa all that
kind of stuff
because by his by really is his own
nature he's an outsider he doesn't
really fit in that he never saw himself
being one of them this is one of those
instances where those barriers start
coming down
and tommy's just kind of like i am a
power ranger and if i'm going to be a
power ranger i have to think like a
power ranger i have to think like a
teammate and so he kind of says okay so
like we've got this guy's arm
let's basically use it to you know
develop one of his energy blasts
we'll fire it into my coin which in turn
will go to you guys and you guys will
basically gain my powers
and that's exactly what happens right
like the crazy thing is when when they
all activate their whole thing right
like morphing time you know and they
they do that whole morphing time thing i
see that when i was a little kid because
i had a morpher
when i was a little kid it was one of
the coolest things but nonetheless like
when that happens
like ultimately they all turn into green
rangers right they're they're not really
dragon rangers they're all their normal
rangers as they are right tyrannosaurus
pterodactyl mastodon you know sleeper
two tiger but they're all colored green
basically we have an entire army of
green rangers here with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this to an end
thank you guys for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace